[Music]
you are watching The Press preview of
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the editor-in-chief of the national
World Cities Newspaper group Nancy
Fielder and the telegraphs leader writer
Tim Stanley so let's see what's on some
of those front pages for you now
lionhearts are broken that's how the
mirror describes England's World Cup
quarterfinal defeat to France tonight
Harry's pain that's the son's verdict on
the England Captain's feelings after
missing that crucial penalty
this is the times all over for England
again
the star uses a French exclusive in its
post-match analysis
and to the people the England team are
Qatar Heroes
The Observer understands the Royal
College of Nursing and the Unison Union
have offered to suspend their
forthcoming strikes if the government
agrees to substantive negotiations
overpay
speaking to the Sunday Telegraph the
shadow Health secretary Wes streeting
describes Health unions as hostile and
says the NHS must reform or die
the express has been speaking to former
labor Home Secretary David blanket who
says that the Christmas strike wave
could cast the country 4 billion pounds
and lose labor the next election
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Nancy Fielder and Tim Stanley welcome to
you both let's start with the Sunday
Times and um obviously the the story
that most of the papers are covering and
that everyone is a living dreadfully
this evening their headline it's all
over for England full stop again Nancy
well yes I mean that sums it up doesn't
it we had very high hopes but let's
admit it we do every match and we do
every big competition and I like most of
the country did believe that it was
coming home and suddenly it's not but
this was a really really good match and
the team played so well there were so
many chances I mean there was obviously
hurricanes Miss penalty but the second
half was full of brilliant football and
I'm not convinced maybe this is just
what English people say but I'm not
convinced that we were the worst team I
think we played incredibly well we
definitely should be coming home with
our heads high and it's not exactly what
England deserved for Christmas and it's
going to be a fairly Grim Christmas for
lots of us but you know what it wasn't a
World Cup where you've got quite the
excitement that we normally had I'd seen
only three cars with the England flags
flying around Sheffield in the last
month and normally you see hundreds so
maybe it just wasn't our world cup but
we've got some really good young stars
and maybe maybe next time around we'll
bring it home you never know yeah you're
not the only one say that they they
actually played well and probably didn't
deserve to lose tonight at least anyway
um Tim what was your reading
oh well I'm afraid I didn't see the
match but I know that England lost it
was it was 2-1 to France uh so well done
France
um I don't know they're not supposed to
say that
no
why
else I think I was supporting Wales in
this challenge okay
um but uh obviously uh it was a game
that many people have been watching and
I'm sure England's sport is a very upset
by the result
um but hopefully the television one I'll
go back to normal what's your view on
the way it's it's covered by the the
papers then a more sort of General View
oh well obviously uh all of them have
put it on the front page I was working
Telegraph this evening and we were
waiting for the right image before we
could send it off to the printers uh
that's very important you've got to
you've got to get the image which
captures that particular moment in the
matching which is
someone's celebrating and someone's
Choice it's all about waiting for the
right sort of image but obviously the
the newspapers have all put it on the
front page uh because um football's very
important to people and uh they and the
whole country would have been watching
it except me I was on a train
Nancy the front page of the sun really
says it all we've got Harry Kane there
literally biting his his shirt and you
can you can feel his pain through that
photo can't you
it was it was his immediate reaction as
soon as it kicked the ball I mean yeah
it was it was a penalty but actually it
is that picture on the front of the
Telegraph and that small inset picture
there it was a fantastic manager going
over to a striker who has done England
really proud for many many years and
many competitions and I would love to
have heard what he whispered in his ears
but he just went around and he really
picked up the team and this is why there
is hope we've got a really strong manjo
let's hope he sticks with us let's hope
he brings through some of the younger
players and they've paid really well as
a team you know fans have got some
incredible individuals but England were
a really really good team tonight yeah
that that photo that you're showing is
uh the manager hugging Harry Kane we can
see um but he has sort of got formed for
that hasn't he because remember with the
Euros there were the shots of him
hugging a sacker and and you do get the
sense that he does really care about
them as individuals
it doesn't he needs to because we all
know
occasion because the person who missed
it is Harry Kane however let's look at
what the manager is doing you can see he
really cares him and it's not easy for
him either is it but he is a great
leader to go around and to pick up his
team and to be the one that says come on
it's all right maybe we haven't done it
this time but maybe we do next time and
there are some really really nice caring
images and actually the front pages
reflect that England did as proud and
that's quite nice to see there is no
there's no sort of no bullying here
although I'm sure there is online if you
look hard enough Tim we um move on to
the the star they've attempts at a
French headline and we saw the shots
from Paris uh this evening the Sean's
Elise lit up with with fireworks and the
French fans outer on the streets um they
could go on to be uh World Cup winners
for a successive year the second year in
a row
oh did they win it before well if they
do I mean that that's quite uh good for
France I thought Germany was always a
team that was good at football or Brazil
but they got knocked out by Morocco I
know that because everyone's natural
supporting Morocco as the new underdogs
uh that's the new uh popular team it
seems to be uh but obviously just if
there's a loser there's also a winner
and uh good luck to them and I I hope
they all um enjoy the contest and uh May
the best man win yeah or team
um we'll leave the the pictures the
Sean's Elise they spectacularly lit up I
have to say and you can imagine the the
street parties going on all night let's
move away from the football to The
Observer now and it seems as if the
unions are open to to calling things off
if pay is discussed and progress is made
in the direction that they're hoping for
that's the front page of the Observer
Nancy
yeah I mean this is much more of a
disgrace than any of the performances
that the England team put in because
this actually really shines a light on
who is causing the problem here and
everybody's talking about how scared we
all are because the key people in our
Health Service have been treated well
enough to want to continue working by
definition they are carers this is what
they do but they actually also care
about their working conditions and their
pay and this story says that they're
willing to put it on hold to not have
these strikes that the government is so
angry about if only the government would
sit down and talk to the unions and I
think the fact that they have to say
that just says so much there is so much
disrespect this is being caused by a
government that doesn't treat people
fairly that has had 12 years to make an
NHS better and has brought it to its
knees they've been other circumstances
but a lot of this is at the government
store and if they can't even be bothered
or take the time to sit down and have
the conversations with the people who
care for our health there's not much
hope as there yeah it's quoted as um Pat
Cullen General Secretary of the RCN
saying that she prepared to press pause
on Industrial action if the health
secretary Steve Barkley agrees to meet
to thrash out a deal and they're saying
that Barclay has held only two meetings
with them in the last few weeks Tim
yes and this reflects complaints made by
the rmt as well you've said that
ministers have not been willing to sit
down with them and discuss train strikes
the government's trying to adopt a
position here of saying uh of trying to
stand back from negotiations and allow
allow stakeholders to debate it between
themselves but at the same time it won't
actively go to war with trade unions so
it just makes the government look a
little bit impotent but if the nurses
were to go on strike that'd be a very
serious business uh it would be
happening this coming week and it's
predicted that up to 15 000 operations
could be canceled and we're talking that
that's all in the context of historic
waiting lists with around 7.2 million
people waiting for treatment now the
nurses were asking for about 90 the
government said that is just too much
and as we'll see from the telegraph page
labor has said that he probably wouldn't
be able to pay that amount if it was in
government either but it now looks like
the nurses are hoping to sort of
transfer that that 19 into a negotiating
position so they can come up with
something closer to the deal they're
getting from the Scottish Cup on pay so
fingers crossed I think most people will
be quite relieved if that particular
strike gets called off but of course uh
there are still strikes going ahead on
the trains strikes on ambulances uh
strikes on Border uh policing at
airports we're looking forward to a sort
of second winter of discontent and as I
say the big question is is the
government going to really go to war
with the unions or is it finally going
to sit down with the individual unions
and strike pay deals even if they're
well above what the current inflation
rate is yes we shall see time of though
is of the essence uh Tim and Nancy for
the moment thank you we are going to
take a break
coming up we'll discuss concerns over
the rapidly rising cost of antibiotics
for strep a do stay with us
[Music]
you're watching the Press preview still
with me Nancy Fielder and Tim Stanley
welcome back to both of you let's take a
look at the times and this story that
we've um featured the last couple of
days actually on on Sky News and this is
the the rising cost of the antibiotics
the use in the treatment of strep a Tim
this is a very troubling concern as you
know there's been an unseasonable
outbreak of strep a which has led to the
death of 16 children
um and pharmacies say that they're
having difficulty supplying uh the
antibiotics that people need over the
counter because the cost has gone up so
dramatically purchasing
from the pharmaceutical companies to
give an example according to the times
uh normally uh capsules cost between
three uh you know normally only cost a
few pounds to purchase capsules from the
pharmacy from the pharmaceutical
companies between three and four pounds
for oral mixtures but some of the prices
that have now been quoted by the
companies are 10 pounds and 67 Pence for
a penicillin oral solution or another
one is 15 pounds and the problem of
course is that pharmacies then can't
recoup those kinds of costs from the NHS
this is then leading to shortages and
counters now the question is is this
about price gouging is this company is
taking advantage or is this as
pharmaceutical companies say down to
Rising costs from manufacturers either
way given this outbreak of strep a it's
a story to be very concerning which the
government no doubt step in
yes and Nancy that that is uh the the
question really whether it's um ethical
for these these Rises at this particular
time
it can't be ethical it kind of it feels
very similar to this to
um us all having to worry about having
the heating on at times when companies
like Sheldon BP are making billions more
in profits I mean how you can profit
here off children dying and parents
being terrified
um there are so many concerns at the
minute and this is just an additional
one but it is really really scaring our
readers I mean in our web figures every
time there's a reported case or concern
around a case in a school everybody
needs to know what everybody wants to
know about it it's a really important
public service that people are informed
for them not to be able to get the
medicine and for them to be overcharging
for medicine when people are absolutely
desperate is disgusting really and it
just shakes your faith in the
pharmaceutical industry and it wasn't
that high anyway often and Tim it's I
mean it comes to something when when
this is forcing parents of sick children
to to travel in search of of medicine
because they're not able to to get their
hands on it
yeah precisely and up against in the
context of everything we've discussed
just before the break uh about cues on
the NHS about waiting lists and other
concerns like that it just adds to
people's sensor that uh
the the systems are not working properly
and that people are getting a rough deal
at a very difficult full time of year
yeah meanwhile in the Sunday Telegraph
we will read that the shadow Health
secretary was streeting is warning that
the Health Service is a service and not
a shrine and it needs to reform or die
this is a very different line for labor
isn't it Nancy
this is a very very different line and
one that I can't help but think is a
huge mistake if the labor party is
saying it doesn't support doctors and it
doesn't support nurses and it's doing
that by attacking the unions then it
just seems an extraordinary due turn
effectively on the history of the labor
party and really really bad timing I
think there is huge support for the
people who keep our NHS running every
day newspapers across the country still
get letters from people saying you know
what I was in hospital I was on whatever
Ward and the staff were incredible and
it's really really hard for those stuff
but I just want to write and say thanks
and that's because we all see these
people we know these people they're our
friends they're us they're people doing
a really really tough job and for the
labor party now to say that it's them
who's stopping the reform and they're
holding the NHS back this just sounds
massively out of kilter with what the
public think and I mean they don't quite
aware they are because because the
tourists are making such a mess it's not
because of fantastic labor party
policies so how you get elected when
you're throwing something like this into
the mix um well I have no idea to be
honest Tim just how significant is this
because labor relies heavily on on Union
support we read here that's accepted
more than 15 million from unions
involved in this Winter's strike
this is a very significant political
development up until now Labor's
position
has largely been to sit back and demand
that's changed for two reasons one
because strategically trying to move
towards the center recapture some of
that Blair right style of 97 remember 97
Blair actually ran to the right of the
Tories on things like tax and crime
likewise uh they're trying to say on
brexit on Asylum and now on the NHS we
can be just as tough-minded as the
tourists but the other issue is that
labor is very probably going to win the
next election and when they do they're
going to take over an NHS which has
enormous waiting lists in which more
money has been poured into a historic
amount but it's not reaching the front
line including Hey where's treating
himself in the interview with the
telegraph says that he has been waiting
for scans uh he's been waiting for the
results of delayed scans for personal
cancer treatment so he personally knows
the effects of these waiting times and
what he's saying is we are not going to
put more money into the NHS without
pledges of Reform without Personnel
saying they're going to deliver more uh
and what and one thing he identified as
something he's very angry about for
example was the BMA BMA voting that GPS
would limit working times between nine
and five how are you going to clear the
waiting times a backlog if doctors are
behaving in that fashion so it's not
just labor strategically positioning
itself to the right of the Tories it's
also labor recognizing that it's going
to have to take over the running the
address it's going to have to reform and
one thing Labor's saying it will do is
it will actually expand the use of
Private health that's why this is a very
significant moment labor has moved to
the right of the Tories on Healthcare
yes it is a significant in that extent
but but West rating is definitely
speaking from excuse me from a personal
perspective saying that Health Service
is facing an existential crisis with
appalling difficulties accessing care is
he wrong on Nancy
no he's absolutely right is it the fault
of the nurse and the doctors who are
thinking of going on strike with
threatening strike no it's not is it
that our reforms needed and actually if
you speak to people in the NHS there are
people individuals in there who have
great ideas for reform and reform is
possible the NHS does not need to die
but we all also know it doesn't need to
be where it is but it's not the people
within the service who are providing the
service who are creating the problems
and look he has got personal experience
but haven't we all I mean one of my best
friend's Granddad died on a trolley
after 24 hours Saturday night just a
couple of weeks ago there are so many
people who are suffering because the NHS
NHS isn't one property but to go up
against the people who run it is not the
right right way talk to them work with
them because they want it better why
shouldn't a doctor work nine to five
that surely there has to be solutions
that don't include running people into
the ground and making forcing them to
leave the NHS because they can't cope
with the circumstance anymore Nancy
thank you sorry for for your loss thank
you both for uh contributing to that
newspaper review